[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Marcellus Wiley former NFL All-Pro
defensive end and host of more to it
great podcast on The Dan Patrick Podcast
Network and uh interviews with him
you talked to uh uh well you talked
about this on the podcast well you said
you were going to answer questions this
past week about the Eagles we're trying
to be too perfect to stay perfect
explain that logic to the audience
yeah it's interesting when you watch a
team go out there and all of a sudden
try to play up to their label and play
up to their results uh a lot of this is
mental and so I saw the Philadelphia
Eagles go into a game where they only
had three turnovers in eight games and
all of a sudden the projection of
perfection and the conversations
continue to be had about them comparing
to the 72 dolphins and you saw a team
have four turnovers in one game after
only having three and eight games and in
those moments when you're trying to do a
big it's always about the little things
and you may take your eyes off of those
little things when you're trying to live
up to a label when you're trying to live
up to being perfect you actually mess up
on all those little things that added up
to that perfect result I saw it on full
display watching those Eagles mess up
those minimum moments
what came to mind when you heard Derek
Carr say what he said after the loss to
the Colts
I was really Disturbed at the fact that
players get into this performance at
times where they have to show that
they're more invested than others
especially when adversity hits like all
of a sudden you see the fracturing of a
team just because we're facing this
adversity so now you have guys who's
supposed to be leaders who are really
raising their hand to show everyone I'm
so committed I'm more invested in my
teammates this is not on me so now
you're seeing guys just go out there and
instead of being selfless they're being
selfish and Derek Carr who I think is
authentic who I think is an emotional
leader for this team has still fallen
short on the football field so the last
thing we need is theater at the podium
to tell everyone that you are the one
that is first in last out like the rest
of the guys are not as committed as you
Devonte Adams echoed what Derek Carr had
to say basically calling out teammates
yeah you know what's so crazy about it
because they're going to be protected or
at least given benefit of Doubt when
you're playing in Sin City as soon as
anything goes wrong we're going to blame
the city we're going to blame the
surroundings we know that and then
you're going to have committed guys who
I assume Davante Adams who I assume
Derek Carr but I also assume other
players on this team so coach used to
always say if you got a problem with the
team and you want to address it publicly
I need names and numbers don't you go
out there and generalize because if
you're gonna step out there and say we
got a problem in here isolate the
problem so you already have violated
what the code is don't tell everybody
our business and if you are be specific
there's this
um rush now to get grass over turf
and I don't know where it's coming from
I don't know if it solves everything but
what do you make of some of the Stars
including Aaron Rodgers coming out and
saying we got to go back to grass yeah I
hate grass so I'm on the other side if
they need anybody to sit there and say
Pro Turf I'll sit here as a retired
player who love Turf come on um look
well football's a hundred percent
guaranteed injury rate no matter what
surface you play on like can we stop
with this old 92 versus 89 like that's
not the conversation I want to have
we're going to get hurt on grass and
turf what happens on grass is it feels
better when you get hurt on Turf it
hurts more when you get hurt but they
both end in the same damn place pain I
love Turf because I was able to perform
better in all conditions I remember
playing in Pittsburgh and they had to
play you know after the University of
Pittsburgh resided the field it was
beach volleyball I remember also playing
on Turf no matter what the weather
conditions were at least I didn't have
to worry about my traction and my speed
so I know I'm going to get hurt if I
play football long enough so get that
out the conversation which surface
allows me to perform the best obviously
that's turf
worst field you ever played on
uh that Pittsburgh feel was pretty bad
uh Cincinnati I think it was my rookie
year we're laying there stretching
pregame and one of my teammates like man
look at this field is slanted and you
literally could look across the fields
and you can see the field was built like
this like it literally was slanted I
don't know if that was for irrigation or
just lazy landscape I don't know who did
this but the field was slanted and the
turf was horrible you can see the seams
in the turf but that was old school
football wide shoulder pads AFL feeling
but of recent memory was Pittsburgh they
need to get that side together we're
talking to Marcellus Wiley the former
All-Pro defensive end and his podcast
more to it the uh latest episode
dropping today
um
maybe it's too soon to bring this up the
Music City Miracle oh God here you go
you must not like me let's go let's do
it were you uh were you a rookie that
year second year with Buffalo uh let's
say second third year yeah I remember
that play vividly where are we going
with this
where were you when it happened
oh man I'm like Derek Carr well no me uh
you know I was on the sidelines crying
like Derek Carr
um I was on the sideline I've been
taking off of our kickoff team because I
got flipped I was one of the best
Gunners in kickoff young players you got
to play kickoff I was doing amazing got
to a Miami game I got de-cleated which
means somebody knocked me off my feet
flipped in the air tackled the guy
caused the fumble Wade Phillips runs up
to me he's like you know what Marcellus
that was amazing and you're never doing
that again because I need you on defense
so I'm on the sideline and I'm watching
the play develop with the best
perspective because I'm on the sideline
and you can see it
when when gash gets the ball he jogs and
as soon as you see a kick returner
jogging set up alarms going off but I
wasn't in I wasn't on the play I wasn't
in the field of battle those guys were
out there and next thing you know you
see a pass to the other side and all we
saw were Tennessee types we didn't see
anybody from the Buffalo Bills on that
side and we know how that all ended it
ended in a lot of tears and a lot of
pain how long did that replay take
oh God in real time Dan I think it was
like 24 minutes or something it felt
like
eternity you're sitting there you're
watching everyone gather around the
officials and all of a sudden it became
like a mob the officials are sitting
there looking through the camera and all
of the crowd seems like they're just
hovering and surrounding them and really
just like being Vigilantes out there
like ah just intimidating them and you
can see the officials like just going
back and forth and when they came out
with the call
I mean it took astrophysicists and it
took MIT to try to break this play down
and I don't think anybody has a
definitive answer but we felt the pain
and the torture and the twisting of that
blade what felt like 20 plus minutes
I've had a couple of callers say this
I've heard some other people use this
analogy that Bill Cowher came out and
was really angry that you know you're
going to hire Jeff Saturday and he has
no coaching experience he was offended
by this but people pointed out did Bill
Cower have any experience to sit in on
the CBS pregame show he jumped the line
I don't think it's Apples to Apples but
can you see where people are trying to
compare the two Saturday move to the
head of the line
Bill Cower moved to the head of the line
to be in TV
oh absolutely
um I think it highlights the greater
problem we have in our world today
there's like a pandering epidemic going
on where people are just saying things
not thinking it all the way through just
because they know it will land safely in
today's culture so this was really a
play of saying oh man Jeff Saturday has
privilege Jeff Saturday has white
privilege uh but I don't know if Bill
Cower will come out and say this if that
were a black coach think about how that
lands oh a black coach can't skip the
line there have been other coaches that
skip the line even though this happens
in other sports and this happened in our
sport Jason Kidd became a head coach
Jason key was just a great point guard
and that turned into being a head coach
you see it all the time and people don't
really understand it because they don't
really respect human capital like
relationships networking all of that is
the fine print of any relationship ship
any contract like if you don't have a
good relationship with someone you're
going to work with or work for you don't
get that opportunity guess what vice
versa occurs as well if you have a
tremendous relationship and you have a
resume that's tremendous in a different
Endeavor we will translate that
relationship and that resume to this new
opportunity I've been the benefit
benefactor of great opportunities
leaping the line skipping the line I
think everyone has because it's not so
merit-based that relationships don't
matter
interesting that let's say it's a
black member of the media
okay and they would get promoted how do
you think the media would have reacted
let's say Ryan Clark of ESPN got the job
he's the head coach of the cult
knows a lot of football maybe it's not
Apples to Apples because he didn't play
for Jim or say in the Colts I'm trying
to think if there's somebody in the
media African-American if they did that
would the reaction have been different
or how much absolutely absolutely have
been different because the culture is in
a different place right now and as
culture is defined by Ben Horowitz the
venture capitalist great guy great
friend culture is what's rewarded it's
not the signs on the wall discipline
desires not be on time it's none of that
it's what is getting rewarded and in
this moment in time you actually will
get rewarded if you sit there and
support an African-American who gets an
opportunity that is deemed usually for
white American so that's something that
we know is getting rewarded right now
there's tons of money being invested
funds all of this interest towards that
so when that happens if you say that
you're going with the flow you're going
with the stream but if you go the other
way obviously what doesn't come as
rewards what comes is consequences bad
consequences and people start to deem
you as either insensitive or even racist
On The Other Extreme so Bill Cowher
knows this he knows this is something
that goes with the flow this is
something that goes with the stream the
mainstream so I know if he would have
went the other way
he knows how that lands and it doesn't
land the same as the way he went
great to talk to you as always
what do you got in store coming up on
the podcast oh what we got in stores
we're going through culture Sports
entertainment uh the fans are responding
with with questions and we're just going
to hit all the topics uh we got
tremendous guests lined up as well
Terrell Owens wants to jump on here had
a conversation with him so we got guys
lined up in conversations to have thank
you Marcellus all right appreciate that
that's Marcellus Wiley former All-Pro
defensive end the host of the podcast
more to it it's on The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network you can get it there or
wherever you get your podcast